Imagine if you could predict the future.
Not perfectly, mind you, but with enough accuracy
that brilliant enough minds - say, the best
and brightest of the SCP Foundation - could
plausibly reverse-engineer the main determinative
factors that caused a certain timeline to
form.
Imagine if, through carefully studying these
determinative factors, the Foundation could
carefully shape the future into one that’s
more favorable for the human race than all
the alternatives.
The “Preferred Option”, if you will.
Would this not be advantageous?
Your next question is a very natural one,
given the circumstances: How does one predict
the future in such a manner?
Well, the answer is uncomplicated, but that
doesn’t by any means make it easy: You go
there, spend a few months looking around,
and then come back to report your findings.
That’s right, folks - We’re not talking
psychics and seers here.
Prepare to expand your mind and please don’t
worry if it all gets a little…
timey wimey.
Because SCP-2003 is the SCP Foundation’s
self-made time machine.
Even most of the staff at the SCP Foundation
itself don’t know about SCP-2003, given
the highly sensitive nature of the projects
surrounding it.
Much like SCP-2000 is a trump card securing
our present in the case of a catastrophic
XK-Class End of the World Scenario, SCP-2003
is our prophylactic for such a thing happening
in the foreseeable future.
What’s far more unique about SCP-2003 is
that the SCP Foundation created this ace in
the hole from scratch.
The SCP-2003 Time Machine was invented over
a 25 year period by reverse-engineering the
anomalous technology of three different classified
anomalies and retrofitting them into our own
non-anomalous framework.
The massive machine is housed in Armed Site
47, a remote and well-guarded facility disguised
as an oil refinery.
While extensive records of SCP-2003’s construction
have been made by the Foundation, and it stands
to reason that the machine could be reliably
and successfully reproduced in a different
context, even the most intelligent scientists
taking part in the project couldn’t explain
how or why it actually operates.
In the words of another mad inventor, “It
just works.”
The operating principles of SCP-2003 are relatively
simple to understand: It is able to break
the laws of the space-time continuum by immediately
transporting anything or anyone placed in
its central chamber to some point in the chronological
future.
The subjects transported forwards will remain
in this future for several months before instantaneously
being transported back to the exact location
they were standing in the future.
In order to prevent some kind of unfortunate
accident, like phasing back halfway through
a wall and becoming unpleasant modern art,
the Foundation has established a secure facility
for travelers to head and wait out the rest
of their time when their mission is complete.
Through extensive testing, including that
which was performed under the purview of Project
XN-SHEPHERD, the Foundation has discovered
a great deal about the nature of time travel
via SCP-2003.
We’ll outline the most crucial caveats here,
so what happens next makes a lot more sense
to you.
After all, if time travel was easy, everyone
would do it.
First, as we alluded to earlier, the data
collected by SCP-2003 on the nature of the
future is often unclear, imprecise, and unreliable.
For example, the data collected from 2003
did prove extremely useful in predicting and
preventing a massive security breach over
at Site-19 in 1997.
So naturally, when it predicted a devastating
series of earthquakes off the West Coast of
the United States in 1999 - an event that
several agents sent through SCP-2003 observed
directly - it came as a shock to everyone
when nothing happened.
The Foundation discovered, following this,
that all predictions needed to be contextualized
through heaps of metadata for it to be of
any real use in predicting or preventing our
specific future.
The Foundation also discovered that certain
individuals had a strangely disproportionate
effect on the unfolding of future events.
Let’s say, for example, SCP-2003 discovers
that a new type of nuclear weapon will be
invented in 2028 and quickly adopted by a
number of leading nations by 2030.
And by 2035, tensions will rise, sabers will
rattle, and this nuclear weapon will be used
en masse to destroy human society as we know
it.
Naturally, in order to prevent this, the Foundation
might see to it that certain groups of nuclear
scientists, certain generals, and certain
world leaders get liquidated.
And yet, another trip into the future shows
that this massive nuclear war was not averted.
But why?
Because, it just so happened that this event
was inexplicably tied to the birth of a little
boy named James Hoskins in Saskatoon circa
2025, despite little Jimmy Hoskins seemingly
having nothing to do with the actual development
of the technology - Seeing as he’s only
ten years old when the bombs start falling.
The Foundation scientists working under Project
XN-SHEPHERD keep a database of all of these
highly determinative individuals, also known
as Magnifier Individuals, so they can keep
tabs on how they’re affecting any future
timelines.
Speaking of future timelines, we’re afraid
to tell you that this penultimate caveat isn’t
exactly a pleasant one: There are few to any
cohesive future timelines where humanity survives
long term.
Bummer, right?
The Foundation calls these loose timelines
“Determinative Sets”, and in the majority
of them, human civilization collapses, all
humans die, and in some cases, the earth becomes
completely uninhabitable to all forms of life.
The Foundation is currently seeking a more
optimistic option through controlled manipulations
of the causal stream in our time, but currently,
all we have is the preferred option: Option
XN.
And if you’re someone who would jump at
the chance to travel into the future and take
a gander at all the wondrous or terrifying
sights, there’s actually one pretty major
caveat of SCP-2003 that we’ve been playing
rather close to the chest: Early Foundation
tests found out that the time travel process
via SCP-2003 is extremely damaging to plant
and animal tissue.
Rather than just going on a wacky time travel
adventure like Doctor Who or Austin Powers,
it’d be a little more like stepping into
a giant microwave while dressed in a spacesuit
made of aluminum foil: You’re gonna die
a horrible death.
But there is one silver lining - well, maybe
not “silver” from your perspective, probably
more like pewter - the Foundation has discovered
a way to viably send human-adjacent subjects
through time with SCP-2003 without instantaneous
death…
We just can’t promise that you’re going
to like it.
You see, the one kind of organic tissue that
seems to survive the SCP-2003 time travel
process is the human brain and nervous system.
Due to the highly controlled nature of Project
XN-SHEPHERD, the Foundation can’t just send
in D-Classes to do the job, they instead use
actual agents - though mostly ones who are
nearing or beyond retirement or are suffering
from a terminal illness.
These Agents are dosed on a course of anti-anxiety,
anti-depressant, and antipsychotic chemotherapy
to toughen their minds for the horrors to
come.
Though the exact nature of these horrors is
kept secret from them until it’s already
happened.
You may be familiar with one of the Foundation’s
most well-known front companies: Boston Dynamics,
as well as one of their most famous products,
the robotic, quadrupedal probe known as BigDog.
Well, in order to send a sentient being through
time without them being completely destroyed
by SCP-2003, the agent’s brain and nervous
system are entirely removed from their body,
and transplanted into the body of a modified
BigDog.
Still think it’d be fun to time travel?
Hey, don’t look so nervous - For everyone
who agrees to be part of an SCP-2003 mission
and survives, you’ll get one hell of a pension.
Or, at least, your family will, if that’s
any consolation.
Now that you understand all this, let’s
come clean about this mysterious “Project
XN-SHEPHERD” we’ve been alluding to throughout
the video.
It all started with a letter to the heads
of the SCP-2003 research project from O5-7,
a member of the legendary O5 Council that
instructs the Foundation in all that it does.
The letter read:
“Up until this point, all attempts at future
intervention using SCP-2003 have been limited
in scope and scattershot in nature.
I have seen the wisdom in this approach; it
is informed by painstaking contingency planning
and risk/benefit evaluation.
The past 18 months of reports, however, have
promise if we are bold enough to seize the
initiative.
We may have found a way out, here.
The price, though.
There's always a price.
As you well know.
Consider this note an official change in policy.
As of today, all efforts at intervention are
now aimed at bringing about and preserving
XN.
Designated Magnifier Individuals associated
with XN are to be protected from undue interference
at the expense of all other priorities.
In particular, Nuru Diagne must be allowed
to die in the manner most observations have
predicted for her.
If anything at all changes in that regard,
make it happen.
I trust that you're familiar enough with the
rest of the Determinative Sets to understand
why we're going this way.”
So, in short, of all the potential timelines,
O5-7 wants the researchers assigned to SCP-2003
to ensure that timeline XN is the one that
actually comes to be, seeing as it’s preferable
to the alternatives.
Hence, Project XN-SHEPHERD.
You’re probably wondering: What happens
in timeline XN that makes it the most desirable
outcome possible?
Well, things continue as normal.
Everything from anomalous activity to social
unrest to environmental factors stays pretty
much the same as time goes on, until 2349
when a giant, 22-kilometer asteroid strikes
the earth and wipes out the majority of humanity
in an instant.
Following this, the world becomes unfit for
human habitation.
Hey, don’t look so glum, you’ll all be
dead by then - Well, except Dr. Bright.
Sorry again, Jack.
We at least get a nice three centuries before
we’re wiped from the cosmic table.
Your next question is probably: If the preferred
option has humanity being wiped out by a giant
asteroid in a little over 300 years, what
are the other ones?
Aren’t we entitled to a multiple-choice
future if we don’t feel comfortable with
being completely annihilated by an asteroid
before we’re even halfway to the year 3000?
Well, we’ll give you a little tasting platter
of potential timelines, and you can take your
pick.
There was the narrowly avoided Scenario XB,
where things progressed in a similar fashion
to Scenario XN, except a massive gamma-ray
burst from the sun in April 2017 wiped out
all life on earth within 38 seconds.
Then there’s Scenario XE, where the birth
of an unnamed boy in Turkmenistan combined
with the election of Sir William Entwistle
as Prime Minister of New Zealand in 2049 leads
to a world-destroying nuclear exchange between
Israel and Greater Indonesia in 2058.
Any attempts to stop it just make it happen
sooner.
Or what about Scenario XH.
Here, a deadly, mutated form of influenza
causes the deaths of over a billion people
worldwide.
Combatting this threat caused increased cooperation
between world governments that actually resulted
in a huge net improvement for global peace
and quality of life.
It seems unrealistic, we know, but SCP-2003
doesn’t lie.
However, despite things going well, all known
life on earth just vanishes on July 29th,
2059.
It’s a hell of an unpleasant twist after
things started going so well for once.
In Scenario XO, the anomalous increases in
frequency and magnitude in 2037.
This leads to a Broken Masquerade scenario
where the Foundation’s web of secrecy collapses,
and anomalous chaos reigns across the globe.
The Foundation’s members are hunted and
killed, and world governments attempting to
weaponize the anomalous leads to a new arms
race that wipes out all of humanity by 2048.
Or maybe Scenario XU is more your cup of tea.
In this one, the sun collapses, leading to
eternal darkness and massive temperature drops.
Inexplicably, humans still survive but are
in a state of constant, unmoving agony.
And maybe if you just really love spiders,
you’ll get a kick out of Scenario XX, where
a mysterious pathogenic protist causes the
majority of humanity to fall in love with
the Brazilian Wandering Spider - One of the
few spiders that pose an actual threat to
humans.
The diverting of all resources meant to keep
humans alive to instead breeding the spiders,
combined with many, many people being killed
by the resulting spiders, leads to six billion
deaths in the early 2030s.
But hey, you’ll get to see some pretty great
spiders, if that’s your thing, I guess.
Scenario XN is hardly a picnic.
Nobody likes the idea of facing an armageddon
straight out of Armageddon when that asteroid
kills all life on earth in 300 years.
But while it undeniably isn’t perfect, it
may just be the best option we’ve got.
Isn’t the future amazing?
Now go check out “SCP-2935 O, Death and
More Epic SCP Stories You Can't Miss” and
“SCP-999 Tickle Monster VS.
the Most Evil SCPs” for more mind-blowing
videos about the entities of the SCP Foundation!